when white nice white people with
clipboards they make you feel
comfortable you start getting emotional
and [ __ ] they're like are you okay it's
fine don't worry about it because um
[Laughter]
[Music]
so uh yeah there's this uh there's this
attorney right
it's in Florida
he likes motorcycles okay and he likes
motorcycles almost as much as he likes
his right and freedom of choice
so when they're like You Gotta Wear a
Helmet to ride a motorcycle he's like no
no no no no no no no you are impeding on
my free rice as a human so he's like I'm
gonna use my [ __ ] skills and my
knowledge to fight this [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] puts down a strong fight and he
actually wins as an attorney and
overturns the need and the lawful right
or need to wear a helmet riding a
motorcycle I already know how he sounds
some [ __ ] let me tell you something
about my ride and then him and his chick
getting to a motorcycle accident
God and [ __ ] die that's hey that's
his [ __ ] right that was his right
that was his right it's his right to die
that guy's in a motorcycle right now
[Music]
yeah but it was my right to kill myself
that's a patriot let me tell you
something when I hear that story I don't
cry I don't [ __ ] look down I salute
the goddamn bit for doing that it was
you're trying to kill yourself
his name was Ron Smith he was an
aggressive advocate for overturning the
law of course what state was this this
is in Florida of course it's Florida hey
let him Rock bro Freedom Florida because
because the same the helmets to protect
the rider dude right and if you get hit
and you fall yeah do I look like [ __ ]
queer
Ron Smith would have said that
[Music]
it was just like
Mr Smith here we have the right to leave
well let's go [ __ ] he's like your honor
how can I hello my beautiful hair in the
wind with a helmet plank about it think
about think about it would I Look to You
Queer I look queer to you
Mr judge man let me tell you something
right now it starts with the helmet and
then they're gonna control us with
Twitter and all that [ __ ] hell now we
gotta be free Freedom it's like you're
right take the goddamn helmet off
it's like the simplest [ __ ] banana
peel bro did you read this article how
do you know it worked for work this is
exactly what happened I'm pretty sure
what happened stenographer is like oh my
God this guy's a [ __ ] wish this guy's
a legend I'm putting that condom tip in
my hair excuse me sir how do you spell
clear yeah every time I put the helmet
on it looks like a penis and I ain't a
[ __ ] penis
Americans the judge I don't know how to
respond to that uh yeah you're right
you're not a penis you're right you're
our Human
Action scratch it so that's right that's
just great granted I don't know what
they say
yes
I don't even know what a judge says
access granted is that what they say I
don't know [ __ ] porn site
let me figure this out hold on let me
figure it out like a meeting adjourned
dude
what is the word that they say and then
they hit the thing I don't know and
we're ending it
yeah
and we're adjourned maybe Court
dismissed I don't know of course oh yeah
Court dismissed and then right all the
other ones are funnier
permission granted access granted up and
sesame like he had the cheat code he's
not wearing helmets dude that's [ __ ]
gnarly that he died of a little [ __ ]
motorcycle accident but she was so
dangerous though that's the only thing
that keeps you safe it's not just him
it's him and his girlfriend that that
how old was he and I picture the
girlfriend was like but I like the
helmet
you watch your [ __ ] mouth I said you
better what the [ __ ] I wear that's
nothing she was age 66 and his uh
girlfriend I don't know but he had a
good run he had a good run he had a good
ride you gotta he had a hell of a ride
you know they were headed to a memorial
service actually when they were on that
ride for another biker who had died of
cancer no
and then Smith crashed the bike as he
tried to slow for traffic ahead of him
both he and his girlfriend were killed
neither wearing a helmet and it was by
way of the coroner they were had drama
death has head trauma yeah life was like
I'm really gonna write this [ __ ] here we
go [ __ ] well dude that's how many people
ride motorcycles and they crash anyway
and they get [ __ ] up with the helmet
on oh yeah dude I went to the hospital
because I cut myself and my finger like
a [ __ ] ass cut but my I was like oh my
God you know I reacted like I was
cutting a bagel and I could oh
and I did the whole freaking out went to
the hospital it's serrated too that's
just a towel too and it was like little
drops dude the whole towel was like big
and it's a little [ __ ] dropped but I
was like I think I see something I think
I need stitches like and I'm trying I'm
scaring I think I'm gay oh yeah coming
sorry come inside please
[Laughter]
and they [ __ ] dip my hand in that
thing and then [ __ ] [ __ ] had x-ray
[ __ ] no it was it was uh uh
um whatever it's called but the [ __ ]
iodine iodine I didn't I dying them like
this and I look like a pedicure I was
just like oh my gosh like I have the
scariest thing everybody was sitting
down she's like what'd it say I just I
don't know one minute you're cutting up
and they're all speaking Vietnamese
oh my God how's your day going the guy
in front of me and [ __ ] he had his
[ __ ] all scratched up he's like oh I
[ __ ] fell off my motorcycle I got a
motorcycle accident and I was like oh I
was like really how's it look and then
he [ __ ] just bone bone imagine if he
said like you want some iodine and his
fingers like his I can see his finger so
this the bone went straight and the
fingers just shriveled up like a little
[ __ ] uncircumcised penis like just
like all shriveled up right here and I
can see the nail all these fingers and
I'm like oh [ __ ] he's like yeah dude I
[ __ ] this guy turn and he [ __ ] hit
him and I flew into my hands went
[ __ ] first what if he goes instead he
goes Bagels am I right
[ __ ] Bagels [ __ ] Bagels but he
just went like that he's like yeah and
then he looked there like a [ __ ] man
he's like yeah
that's all he needed to say and he was a
[ __ ] Madness yeah
he's just like [ __ ] I want to get out
of here so I can get ready right
get ready to ride and I'm just like
I'm just like looking at my little
finger and [ __ ] didn't even Stitch me
off they just put a banded like a
butterfly Bandit and I was telling them
no I think any stitches they're like you
don't need [ __ ] sticks that [ __ ]
black lady was Matt you need you can go
now [ __ ] did they ever ask you like on a
scale of one to ten ten being the worst
like how much I said 11 because
just mental drama that I'm getting from
there can never cut a bagel again that
means such a [ __ ] about it dude I
[ __ ] was so mad at myself afterwards
I'm like especially the [ __ ] the
hospital bill I'm like really how long
did you wait for the year you probably
could have just wrapped it up yeah and
then I waited like [ __ ] five hours
right for some [ __ ] little thing
where I just could have went home and
put a bandit on myself I was being such
a [ __ ] about it but the lesson you know
they planted that really masculinity
right there and they could never go to
the hospital yeah dude I was always that
token guy there yeah but let me tell you
in a moment I was sure my life was over
I was like
and I did because if I had I'm like I
killed I like I [ __ ] sliced a vein
something happened it's gonna get
infected I don't know I think I got a
gay cut I don't know what happened yeah
I don't know what's going on he's gonna
die now I just feel like what the [ __ ]
is this it was I thought I saw bone but
it was just like tissue
Bagels you know get a bagel slicer you
don't even want to know how the [ __ ] oh
to it
you want to know what the [ __ ] happened
what happened nah because it sounds like
some [ __ ] I'm not saying it doesn't
sound great
you're not gonna believe what happened
all right so is that a bagel it was a
bagel okay no it was a bagel but it was
a Cocker Bagel dude so
so this is what happened dude it was
like uh I'm doing stand up and then I
started Living with another comic it was
like a known comic like it's Jeff Garcia
I don't know if you guys know he is but
he's his voice over work and stuff and
he started like he got the sitcom that
was called Mr Box Office or something
like that and it was like uh [ __ ]
Vivica Fox was there that was the
biggest name that I was like but a bunch
of John Lovitz all these people were
there and I go with him because you know
I'm just like you know the driver I
drove him over there so I'm over there
and I'm [ __ ] and I'm trying to like
you know us or me at least I'm very like
I don't want to you know blend I just
want to blend in I don't want to cause
attention I want to be like because I
don't know if I'm allowed to be here and
then they showed us the crafts uh table
right where they have all the the toast
and [ __ ] so I'm getting hungry and I'm
like I'm gonna get a bagel and I'm
trying to be calm and Vivica Fox is
right here talking to me and I [ __ ]
slice and I'm talking to her because I'm
nervous and I'm like here so you're you
know you're an actor and look at a nice
slice he's like oh my God baby baby you
cut yourself and I just [ __ ] felt the
cut and I started bleeding and I'm like
oh [ __ ] and then she's just like oh my
God baby baby let me see it and I'm like
no no it's fine it's like I'm dripping
on the bagels I'm making the biggest
scene because he like the guy told me
like dude just chill just blend it in
you know I'm the crafty dude [ __ ]
scene with the [ __ ] bagels and I'm
dripping and I'm just like oh [ __ ] it's
fine it's fine because I really went
deep you know and then the people came
in like and now they're asking who are
you getting here like who brought you
here and I'm like no um I know him
when white nice white people are
clipboards they make you feel
comfortable you start getting emotional
and [ __ ] they're like are you okay it's
fine don't worry about it because um
here's the thing
I didn't try to cut the bagel I just
like I slanged it and then it's the
[ __ ] night
they were like making it a scene and
they were just like here's the thing go
to the hospital this and that and I'm
like no I'm good I'm gonna go to the
hospital and that's when I was like all
right all right I'll go to the hospital
and just make sure they called and they
took me to the hospital and that there
was the ones that kind of made it a bit
Yeah because we were like because I was
on Sand and like you know insurance and
[ __ ] so they make sure they got a guy to
drive me over there so I went to the
hospital and that's what happened but
but yeah dude that's what really
happened I made a big scene of mess it
was so [ __ ] embarrassing
the next famous person who walks over to
craft he's like oh yeah yeah
I come back like five hours later dude
with the [ __ ] thing raps
I was the guy that lost all that blood
[ __ ] he turned on pale my little orange
juice
you need to give me the oranges and the
crackers in the hospital
like you donated
[Laughter]
[Music]